I love dumplings but her seldom have
dumplings in the restaurant because my
mom's cooking is the best one day I
happen to take a bite of dumplings this
dish
to my surprise they had a flavor of
going home fresh chewy and then expected
in addition to be a daunting lover I
actually have a full-time job I am a
management consultant so naturally I was
keen to understand the reasons behind
those delicious dumplings what I didn't
expect is that this dumpling triggered
my exploration of new ways of management
in China a change that has deeply rooted
in Asian Chinese philosophies but first
let's go back to the dumplings counter
foo found a dumpling see 17 years ago
today the company enjoys 500 stores were
8,000 employees but it wasn't always the
case three years ago the demand for his
dumpling was soaring due to consumers
craving for healthy food but the strong
growth of online food did resurface had
poor the consumers away from the store
visit causing a huge concern for Gao if
I were to advise Carl back then I would
go directly with classical approach
hiring venturing managers providing
training on how to integrate online
offline sales or having some high
potentials fully dedicated to the new
job such as chief digital officer but
Gao did something totally different
he invented a 2 hat model instead of
recruiting new executives he invited 5
successful regional heads to take on a
second role at headquarter the cat was
the hata - it was to be
the frontline managers keep in mind that
these people had no formal training or
related experience in this field we did
he had though with natural strengths and
a growth mindset when girl first told me
the idea I said are you sure I have
seldom seen companies as large as laws
to have part-time senior executives but
girl smiled this is my dumping way
girl's team was so puzzled in the first
three months the sales fluctuated some
even dropped by 20% but GAO didn't blink
the regional has had to learn new skills
were still doing their job things like
what kinds of dumplings can be sold
online how to digitalize their supply
chain after the transition period
something magical happened the sills
come back one year later the company
began to launch his fresh and spicy
dumplings online two years later more
talents with startup dreams were
attracted more importantly the company
began to translate these individual new
capabilities into company policies and
roll them out a true differentiator
compared with his peers because most
Chinese entrepreneurs are very good at
growth strategies in Chinese recorded
hide young photo
expanding territories but not so good at
what we call to war and bong converting
individual best practices into company
policies for the long run the nature of
GAO's approach such as having tolerance
of frontline managers to make mistakes
or having some new ideas not coming from
the top is not common in China because
they go against our traditions in the
past 2,000 years Confucianism has been
dominant in China which values seniority
and moth or 'ti for a nation
this is a time-tested formula to ensure
order and harmony for a company this
ensures precise execution at a large
scale but with business environment
constantly changing internet disrupting
traditional industries new Millennials
become a major workforce new ways of
management emerge I feel so lucky to
study this in such a dynamic age were at
the same time to satisfy my stomach with
delicious dumplings girls too had
approached it just one example another
example comes from Miranda to the
founder of shahanshah
sir horseshoe is a thriving internet
company with 300 million users it is an
online community where young fans can
get together to talk about their
favorites or proper gogo squid or buy
the crew shoes that the lead actress
wears in a running sing from the early
days she wanted the whole organization
to be ready to spot on things that need
to change and challenge the authority
but one day she noticed her interns were
calling senior staff teachers this may
sound innocent by a signal a problem to
chew because if the teacher phenomenon
become a norm if we encourage hierarchy
and discourage ownership this is also
something related to confusion thinking
in Chinese we call it benefit Ben means
me myself fen means the share of the job
I would just focus on my job and not
cross analyze which is totally the
opposite to choose thinking so to create
a unique initiative toward signature
program in the program each employee
chooses an avatar counter that props up
a long sized digital communication
channel some common ideas include
captain hook her reporter a many
well-known characters in Chinese
literature the way these characters
interact
proved to be the answer to choose
problem avatars from the same story
we'll get together to talk about their
favorite characters in the community
called slam dunk people from different
cities different departments different
levels of the organization they will
talk about how these characters inspire
them at work an employee with a
signature chord coach ends I was facing
some difficulty in leading a very young
team other dunk fans will share the best
practices on how to motivate a
diversified team and inspire them to
work to their full potential the
signature program plays a pivotal role
in fostering a collaborative environment
as yahushua not only the teacher issue
has disappeared the company has been
ranked as one of the most innovative
chinese companies by forbes in the past
two years girls who had approached and
choose signature program are just two
examples of empowering the frontline
staff but these methods may not always
be right
let's take Finland for example very
successful insurance company the company
couldn't adopt such approach for the
whole organization because one the
company has 400,000 employees the line
between innovative chaos and chaotic
chaos is very thin
- the company has five equal systems and
ten plus sectors health care insurance
real estate smart city very difficult to
apply a bottom-up innovation to all but
the company stealing needs to be
innovating manager the founder positions
the headquarter as the steering wheel
steering innovations and new ideas
cascading them down to these
subsidiaries one of the ideas that
headquarter came up with is a I enable
loss assessment
not so complicated case the car owner
can take a picture of the damaged car
upload it online the Insurance Center
can decide a claim amount in right away
by AI enabled Lots assessment facial
recognition ID verification the car
owner can get a payment in a few minutes
which could have taken a few days so for
companies that are difficult to conduct
grassroots innovation a centralized
approach is also an option
the more I see these unconventional
method management mechanisms gal with
two hats chu with signature program and
Mar with still real the more I ponder
where do these mechanism come from
they're definitely not confusion they
are very similar to another Asian school
of thought Taoism Confucianism believes
the way to achieve perfection is to
organize and regulate things but tourism
believes in letting things work to their
perfection naturally to support their
natural state and to let him transform
spontaneously in other words leaders
should not impose their will
leaders who act by shaping the context
rather than control Confucianism
works best in weaning a stable context
whereas Taoism with his power to save
the context is more effective in dealing
with uncertainty a leader is best when
people barely know Hayes's when work is
done people will say we did it ourselves
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]